patrick what's the reason you don't edit
your own films
um well i actually
do quite a bit of editing on wordplay i
did a lot of editing on that film
um that was our first film i've done
less and less
as we move forward um when we were
making wordplay that was our first film
and really the only disagreement that my
wife christine and i had
about the making of that film was
i said you know i i'd like to just edit
it because
i know how to add it it'll save us a lot
of money and let's do it and she said no
he said you you we got to bring in
a fresh set of eyes and i remember
thinking okay
fine we'll hire an editor we'll have to
raise more money
but you know i'm sure my friend doug
blush is not available because he's
never available because he's always
working
but i'll call him and see if he can
recommend somebody i called him
he was available and that made all the
difference in the world
i mean you really because i shoot my own
footage
i'm really close to the mature material
already
um but i think you end up with a better
film if you have another set of eyes
a very you know creative individual like
doug doug blush is just a spectacularly
talented
editor and you know i learned a lot
there i i he saw things in the footage
that i would have never seen
so you know that was that was a
that was an important decision for us
like what i'm just curious what what
examples like were there certain details
that you overlooked maybe that he
was like a light bulb went off well i
mean doug is really
funny and really smart he's got a great
sense of humor
and so for instance in wordplay
you know we had all these different
characters who
are um somehow involved with the new
york times crossword puzzle
you know either they make the puzzle or
they are really good at solving it
or they're we had a lot of sort of
famous people in the film
um who who like the puzzle quite a bit
so
doug just had a great ability to take
one character
and put it right next to another
character and another character he had a
great way of sort of
lining up the film um
and and so for instance there was a
scene in the movie where we're
interviewing
jon stewart and jon stewart
i mean he was great he was he was just
really funny um not surprisingly
um and he says in his interview
he says you know he's holding the puzzle
on his hand and he says um
you know i have tremendous respect for
people who make these puzzles
i i i don't know how they do it quite
frankly i don't know why they do it
and then you that's where doug cut to
merle regal who's a very famous
crossword puzzle constructor
he's driving down the street and he says
oh yeah look at that sign there dunkin
donuts put the d
at the end you have unkind donuts which
i've had a few of in my day
like that's just that's a one plus one
is three
that that's that is such a good cut i
would have never thought to do that
and you know that's what a great editor
does i mean they're great
they're not just great on story um
they're also great great on transitions
getting in and out of scenes and and
it's it's really it's really terrific
doug has been a wonderful um
collaborator with us on all of our work
and what about the times when
you think a scene or statement should be
there
and then that editor says you know what
that's two that's
beating them over the head with it or
were there times when he tried to rein
you in with certain things or
was it mostly little fine details i mean
we
our rule here is the best idea wins
and usually the best idea it's it's very
very plain to see like what's the best
way to cut a scene what's the best way
to
cut an act what music cue works what
music cue isn't working etc
and so
yeah we don't have that many
disagreements honestly
um i was really lucky to work with
a really talented young editor younger
editor
doug is pretty young too but younger
than doug
a guy named nick andert and he we hired
him pretty much like right out of
college
um and he started as an assistant editor
and then he basically moved up he became
kind of the primary editor of if you
build it
and you know nick
nick has a great eye and he's got a
great ear
and i think the only things generally
the only things i would encourage nick
to do
was to maybe slow down the edit a little
bit a lot of the things he cut
were really pretty tight and and
efficient possibly
maybe a little too efficient and so i
found that
i would oftentimes ask him to maybe slow
some things down a little bit
but again nick is a lot like doug nick
nick
is just a tremendous storyteller and
was really like a key key part of our
team on this film
i mean it's really i think it's as much
nick's film as it is
our film he's spent over a year editing
the film
um and so i think he's playing that
helicopter too
he's making sure that yeah and
so you know he just did a she just did a
great job
we've been very lucky to find good
editors with our work
do you think that quick edit is a uh
sort of a generational i do
because i'm noticing for myself being a
little bit older i like things that are
slower paced
maybe not dinner with andre slow pace
right but a good good movie excellent
but still just a little slower whereas i
see a lot of newer things with younger
editors much faster and i was just
wondering if it's an age
i do i think that is the case i really
do
um you know and i'm just talking
i'm talking a second here a second there
five seconds here
you know it's he's really good
nick is very very good it's annoying how
good he is for his age
um uh you know uh we'll still be nice to
him yeah no i mean he's really talented
um but um um you know
i i mean i i think i'm a good
collaborator i certainly try to be
and um the one thing
about working with with editors on our
films is that like i said like
most of the footage i've shot myself and
as i'm shooting it i take
i take you know notes every day at the
end of a shoot i call my field notes
and i i just write down
the the handful of sound bites the
handful
of images the handful of ideas that
i think we're going to use in the film
or we'll try to use i mean
we try to sift sift the story as we're
making it
um and so you know there are times with
with
i think with any editor where you're
like you know there's something in there
that i think we're missing
i want you to just see if you can find
this one sound bite or this one shot or
something
um but i you know more often than not
whether it's doug or nick
we work with an editor named daniel
clark who's terrific
they've seen it they considered it and
then they realized it wasn't right for
the scene and
actually usually they're right so it's
fun i mean the editing
is um i think editing is filmmaking
you know as a as a cameraman um
i don't know i just always thought that
you know when you make a movie it's grab
a camera and go shoot it
and obviously you have to have that but
if it's not well cut it's
it's it's not gonna work i mean it's you
have to for our movies you have to take
100 or 200 hours of footage
and make an 85 minute film that's really
hard to do
but that's just that's that's it that's
really where i think
the most important work is done
you